Hello Freak bitches.
I want you to see a box or go to the UFC and see how that's going to happen
eventually.
You know what I mean?
We had James,
Tony of course,
but James was way past his prime and it didn't even look like he trained for
that fight.
I think James just took a payday.
If I had a gas,
you know,
and Randy just hit him with a low ankle pick,
took them down.
I think maybe hit a low single,
I forget what it was,
but he,
he went way low.
But either way there's not a chance in hell the James Tony was ever gonna stop
Randy couture from taking them down.
It's just not going to happen.
He would have to catch him absolutely perfect coming in for the very first
punch.
And if he didn't,
Randy was going to molest him.
See how his way with them excited about GSP?
Yeah.
I'm,
I mean,
I'm interested to see what happens.
Uh,
quite honestly I wanted to see him at one 70.
I want to,
I as I think him versus Woodley is the fight.
Like Woodley's had two fights in a row where people like were booing him and
three really,
cause he had two fights with Wonderboy that were like chess matches.
And then one fight with Damien Maia,
which was also like just not the most exciting fight.
But I think him versus GSP would be very exciting fight.
I think that's the real fight because that's GSPS real weight class too.
You know,
I'm interested in that.
But I'm interested in the Bisping fight too cause I think it's a tough fight.
It's a tough fight for GSP.
Bisping is a handful.
He's a big fella to fought at two oh five and the ultimate fighter fights in one
85 in the UFC.
He's way bigger than George and he's gotten fucking tough man.
He's real good.
Legitimately real good.
And George has been out for a long time.
Yeah.
What's he been doing?
And while he's been training,
he's definitely stayed in shape.
He did a lot of gymnastics,
did a lot of exercise.
You know,
he made a shit ton of money when he was fighting.
he had contracts with Nike and he had some,
he had a,
was it Nike or was it,
um,
I think you had something that we,
I know we had something with Gatorade,
but I want to say Georgia at some would.
Maybe it's under Armour.
I think he's got something with under Armour.
Yeah.
So he's had a bunch of big endorsements and he's at a giant hero in Canada.
I mean,
just giant.
Right?
So I think for,
you know,
a while he's just recovering and then all those wars,
all those years of getting brawls and finally got to a point where his body
started feeling real good again.
He's like,
fuck it.
Let's get back in there.
[inaudible]
okay.